here we go off on another venture it's a
new week and this time I'm taking off to
Palm Springs California. See you babe!
Bye sweetie. Be  back in a week. I'm in Palm Springs
California today got in late last night
for an event called clamor con not
really sure exactly what it is I just
know there's gonna be about 300 creators
here and I got in late last night it was
too dark to see anything so we're going
to go for a walk and see what there is
to see
there's some kind of fruit in this tree
grapefruit tree
so clamor con what exactly is clamor
con I actually have no idea I'm here to
find out apparently there's going to be
over 300 different YouTube creators that
come hang out so I'm looking forward to
meeting all them and just stop for a
second here because I have the new
Galaxy S8 plus that I've been meaning
to unbox this has been sitting in my
house for about two weeks
and I just haven't had a chance to open it up
looks like a good place for an unboxing
beautiful. This right here is my S7 this
is what I've been using for about the
last year and if we compare that to the
S8 you can see the S8s a little bit
taller
it's got maybe a half inch on the top
there a little bit longer so I bought a
new case I like these cases because they
got a little kickstand in the back and
we're going to make the switch first
peel off the bit on the back introduce it to its new case
beautiful there we go we have got a wild
Dennis Roady out of natural habitat whoa
what's up you make a beautiful
silhouette man ready to party? Yeah let's go! breakfast
time your day here's the menu look at
those prices but whatever it oh dude
that bowl of cereal is only nine dollars I had a $17
turkey sandwich last night bro it's a
turkey sandwich seventeen you know the
more you pay the less you get you get that's what I've noticed
noticed ooh
there we go breakfast is served dang I thought
you were a little bit healthier
Mr. Thompson yeah I'm all about being
healthy man yeah (laughing) nailed it bro speak
to the birds you're still working on
yours over here oh I'm done now I had all
the eggs I'm not... this is my seventeen
dollar piece of toast
people always tell me that I'm short but
it's only because I stand next to guys like this you're not short  there's like a major height difference
I'm just a giant I'm tall to
everyone that's why he has giant frames too so I'll be standing there and like I'm just gonna sit down just had
breakfast with this guy
we're going to be headed back to
his hotel room now we got a VR setup
virtual reality I actually haven't played
video games since n64 since company Oh
it'll be mind blown dude I got a bit I'm
pretty dang excited to see what this
world is all about. And this is the covert if you turn the light past the door PCHHH!
dude my hotel room did not come with a
green screen setup so when you're
playing the game online people are
watching you play and your silhouette is
just on the same game screen oh no way
really versus having like a white wall
on this beautiful crazy game that
they're watching interesting so you do a lot of
twitch live-streaming
I just started and you're able to do
like overlaying on the green screen in
the background exactly yeah so here's
the HTC vive right and these are your hand
paddles that you're going to use to play
the game interesting cool so you got
trigger on the back side yep here put
this on that's cool I can see the
controls just like floating yeah so I'm
gonna pop your earbuds in okay? okay
yeah I feel like I'm like working at an
amusement park right alright mr.
Thompson you're going into the zone
right now bud let me know I have to
admit I'm a little bit nervous right now
grant is in the game right now check it
out this is what he's viewing right now
inside this world so you have the
buttons on the inside of your controller
oh there you go yeah you got now you're
holding it and make sure you don't
forget to grab that gun to your left
definitely want to hold on to that this
is freaking
sweet wait till you get into it man
Nintendo 64 was cool but I think this one
takes the cake what do you think about the whole
gameplay man my mind is blown for real it's
pretty random thing to be doing today
huh you called it and I'll get I don't
want to give you too many tricks because
I want you to figure you're definitely
going to die okay okay it's tough so
it's just like the beginning stages
right but all right man let's do it
right get ready is going down (laughter) what happened? Oh you made it!
good job dude you got some more coming. You're so serious! Your face!
yeah well is like I'm surprised I like
Alright thanks for the tip man. BRAHH! (laughter) Not fair! Not fair. You
were not in the game
Oh Oh no! Did you see that oh hi I didn't
know you're here
how cool is that? That's crazy that mask is
freaking sweet dude!  Armfritmarsharshwight
Back in my day we killed zombies with our hands boy! okay I did pretty
good there right better than I did
first try oh man I gotta go find that
other gun though because okay I'm
sweating I'm sweating my heart's racing
this is incredible thumbs up I think I'm
hooked
I think I'm hooked yeah you see that
minus the flicker yeah minus the flicker
and the focus there we go that's what
I'm seeing that's what I'm seeing
dude that's sweet what is this for oh I
just got the mask juices silly silly
gags you know you've done this in one of
your videos that right no I haven't used
it yet
I've just seen on your Instagram stories
then yes I've seen that mask before yes
okay Instagram stories Dennis Roady
folks obviously some big stuff coming up
that's epic
Whew! Just finished a pretty intense session
VR session with Dennis Roady oh my
goodness I've never experienced graphics
in gaming like that like it sucks you
right into the world so my adrenaline is
pumping so hard right now and I didn't
even realize that we just killed four
hours so I'm taking a little breather
going back to the room checking a video
for upload tomorrow and then maybe just
go and chill by the pool a little bit if
we can run into here. Home sweet home. This is
the view from the room. Thank you
remember guys when you eat you're hamburgers
eat them upside down that's what I do.
Quick update guys we got a little
kick-off party happening right now
starting to cool down so I'm gonna go
grab a little jacket a lot of cool
people here we're just going to go hang
out for a bit and then call it a night
What's up? Hey, is that a camera?
good morning guys day 2 this is where
everything kicks off I think they're
going to have all the events in the
seminars so haven't had breakfast yet
it's almost 10:30 I'm kind of starving
but check this out. I tagged my badge
that makes me unique.
I hear little kisses coming through your eyeball that's
a little creepy
apparently there's a water balloon fight
so we're taking the golf cart.
Okay so update guys we managed to stay
dry we skip the wait for the party got
this guy over here from Seattle he has a
channel called punish approxiately
so we're going to hang out and we're
going to talk EVA foam and 3d
printing day 3 is just about over we're
heading out with this group of fine
people we're going to go do something
healthy escape room which I've never
done before it based on the movie
The Saw so I'm slightly terrified yeah I
don't want to work well under pressure I
think I think we're doomed really
I've been told I look like Every Ure from us again
Wait what a saw room? Nobody told me about a saw! I think this is going
to take a little bit of teamwork I have
no idea what to expect but it's going to be
epic I think. Here's a shot of Bill's face
the big thing is here is it says a real life
escape game oh my gosh you're right it
says real life what if we don't come out that's
what I'm terrified about you know I'm gonna
be like I'm a good man
it's all about me yeah
oh yeah okay all right here we go
breaking the rules already
just got a really dark really fast oh I
didn't realize we got a timer we've only
got 60 minutes! We're stuck in this room
right now we got 60 minutes to figure out
clues; we're looking for an 8-inch key let me show
you I figured out
we're making a little progress we found some clothes
we got a lot of things
oh wow somebody found a lot of
cockroaches that's nice. We got clues, we got puzzles, oh yeah body
parts. Interesting okay well they have
numbers up here. And we have 42 minutes.
We're saved! we made it guys! We made it guys. We
solved the problem we found the key the
only problem is we did it one minute
after the timer went off ah that's great
thank you
well guys it's day four clamor con is
finished it was really cool event and
got a chance to hang with some really
cool creators back at the Palm Springs
Airport now I'm heading home so we look
for you in the next video talk to you then.
you got any grandmas looking for a date
hit me up